good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
and i'm proud to welcome you to this
edition of our 2021 2022 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
the lecture series is supported by uva's
integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences the school of data
science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical
sciences this year's theme for the but
for our biomedical data science seminar
series is ethical challenges of
artificial intelligence biomedicine
where we enjoy presentations on friday
afternoons from leading thinkers about
the promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with ai applications in the
biomedical sciences selected
participants in our biomedical data
science innovation lab program will
leverage these presentations as a vital
material for our culminating in-person
grant project development workshop to be
held here in historic charlottesville
virginia next june
applications for the biomedical data
science innovation lab program are being
accepted until january 31st 2022 so
please if you are interested consider
applying and or encourage your junior
colleagues to do so we look forward to
reviewing these application materials
for your participation today it is my
honor and privilege to welcome our
speaker ms johanna loomba who's the
director of the i thrive informatics
corps here at the university of virginia
johanna lumba has a degree in symbolic
systems uh neural systems from stanford
university and a master's degree in
systems engineer from engineering excuse
me from the university of virginia she
has extensive clinical research
experience and previously served as the
director of neurosurgery and
neuro-oncology clinical research for the
university of virginia in her role with
i thrive johanna is the director of i
thrive the i thrive informatics corps
which is a cross-state team working to
accelerate health research by
facilitating data transfer and linking
and analyzing
data in a secure environment in addition
to designing systems that support all of
the ithrive service lines johanna
provides personal consultation to health
researchers on project design
implementation
and including plans for data collection
for project management and for data
analytics in continuing our
2021-2022 biomedical data science
seminar series theme johanna's lecture
today is entitled introduction to the
use of structured medical records data
electronic medical records data emr data
is encoded in patient charts through the
course of clinical care and subsequent
patient billing
excuse me coded data in electronic
records such as information stored
against standardized codes provides a
vast amount of valuable patient data yet
the effective applying of data science
tools to emr data requires an
understanding of the limitations of
those data sets and avoiding common and
false assumptions johanna's going to
address those for us today as she
introduces some common data models
cohort exploration tools and ctsa
related resources
she's going to specifically feature
examples from the national covid cohort
collaborative to demonstrate approaches
to structured health data access
analysis
as always if you are streaming this
lecture live and uh we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording by
youtube and if you're watching on
youtube thank you so much for joining us
also our specially selected
2021-2022 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions for
johanna via the chat feature in their
zoom sessions i will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf
during last 10 minutes or so of
johanna's lecture and with that thank
you so much johanna we've been looking
forward to this talk for a year and
we're really glad to have it today thank
you so much
thank you jack thank you for having me
here
so yes as jack mentioned i'm a clinical
researcher and a systems engineer and i
currently serve as the director of
informatics for the nih-funded i thrive
ctsa
so we are across virginia collaboration
we work with a lot of public private
academic and community partners and the
primary partners are shown here on the
screen together we provide clinical care
to about 60 percent of virginians and
one reason we built this collaboration
was to develop systems and processes
that would support efficient cross-state
observational health research that can
accelerate innovation and support
evidence-based practice
we also work to support team science by
building bridges between data scientists
and clinical researchers
and for much of my career i managed
neurosurgery neuro-oncology
trials and we focused on prospective
data collection but i found that
understanding the challenges of quality
prospective data collection really does
inform the observational research
biomedical data science research should
always include team members who
understand that clinical science and the
practical clinical workflows that
generate the data
and as you'll hear today the development
of the most powerful coding vocabularies
that we have has really been driven by
clinicians
and for those of you here who are
clinicians understanding these topics
coverage should help you better engage
with the analysts who you work with and
my aim is to really just flesh out some
foundational concepts so we can
establish a strong foundation for your
biomedical team
science
and so what are we talking about today
and why
this medical record harmonization is
very relevant to both patient care and
research
the patients benefit from continuity of
care across sites
and the government has also recognized
that in the last decade or so
in 2009 the high tech act motivated
implementation of electronic medical
records for sites that didn't already
have those in place
and in 2016 the 21st century cares cures
act established plans for tefka
which will support greater
interoperability between those different
emrs so that's still in the works and
the first versions expected out in 2022
which is really exciting
so you know patients also as we know
should benefit from translational
research and once harmonized our vast
stores of this clinical record data can
be tapped to solve medical problems
but you know through the covid pandemic
this whole country has come to
understand that research and clinical
care are really intertwined
and also understand that the ability to
pool our data is critical if we want to
quickly identify patterns and evaluate
interventions and outcomes
we really needed tefka two years ago
but luckily researchers have been
working for decades to harmonize health
record data and thanks to all the prior
groundwork laid academic institutions
were able to work
with the nih to quickly spin up the
first massive central repository of row
level health data from patients around
this country
and although kovit was the catalyst for
this unprecedent level of of cooperation
we've established
tools now that are extensible to all
kinds of research questions in any and
all health domains
so this is really a very exciting time
for biomedical research in this country
so this is a summary of what i hope
you're going to gain i'd like you to be
able to name commonly used data models
understand some of the challenges and
considerations around using the coded
data know about tools and resources to
help you
and
be aware of some of this work being done
by the ctsa community and the nih to
harmonize medical data
coded medical data i think jack provided
that summary in the intro it's really
any any of these facts that we have
represented codes in the in the chart
but
is only the first
step towards harmonization is having
those codes available
um our emr data is incredibly complex
and iran counts on the number of
emr codes currently used in the national
coveted cohort collaborative database
that we're talking about today
at the time when i i took this snapshot
there were 65 us sites with data on the
enclave there's 67 as of today it's
growing all the time
but of those 65 sites there's over 75
vocabularies in use and i've shown them
from the most frequently
or the highest counts rather the highest
counts of codes in use
and you know going down the list here
and i couldn't fit them all on the
screen but there's over 6.5 million
unique codes that are represented in the
patient charts that are in the enclave
right now so really really complex
encoding of all this kind of information
that we all want to use to answer our
questions
so you can note that the highest number
of the codes up in the top most of the
categories for the top represent drugs
because we need a lot of different codes
to to identify those
and then that's followed by diagnosis
codes
and then you see things for procedures
measurements and observations
labs locations etc
you'll notice that snowmen appears in
multiple categories so that can be used
kind of across these different domains
and even within a single vocabulary
there can be a lot of variation
in usage
between clinical sites so if you want to
explore an example of this
link is is a particularly good example i
provided three articles in the
references that describe complexities
around the use and evolution of light
codes
so how do we analyze data that's
expressed in so many different
vocabularies each with its own
hierarchical structure
i think you all have heard about the
fair principles and we're going to
explore approaches to these
principles and we're going to find out
that the first two are easier to achieve
than the last two
making your data findable and accessible
dumping billions of rows of data out
somewhere
is one thing but really doing that in a
meaningful way
where it's interoperable
across sites or even across clinics at
your own institution
and then being able to ask questions and
come up with answers
using code that's reusable is a much
bigger challenge
what we need is a common data model and
that is a shared language consisting of
both the data elements in one or more
vocabularies
living inside of a structure that
describes the relationship between those
data elements so the data models both of
those two things put together
you could say that each
emr is in its own way a complex data
model
so for example the 20 000 plus clarity
databases that store epic emr data plus
the epic software that defines the
relationships between the database
elements
together that's a data model
but we have to remember that each site
that implements epic does some amount of
customization so no two epic sites have
the same
real emr data
model so typically the more specialized
the data the more it varies between the
sites and we have to restructure our
data to really approach harmonization
this typically involves mapping the data
that's stored in your thousands and
thousands of tables to a small set of
about 20 or 40 tables while still trying
to retain its meaning
and keep in mind that once you harmonize
data there are still
inherent in that pattern's local
patterns reflective of local data
management practices heterogeneous
genius patient populations and clinical
practices
once the data is harmonized it does
become possible to observe these site
level variations in a way that can't be
achieved just using a single site
most academic health centers in the us
have mapped their data to one of these
common data models
and the map data is used to support any
number of analytic tools
so you may not recognize the terms here
you may or may not but you would
definitely recognize the tools that you
use that sit on top of those
so
note that the counts here are a little
outdated as i pulled this from a 2019
publication pertaining to all of us
research program
and the count for sites using omop is
definitely higher now that is the
fastest growing
data model and is used for most of the
national international
harmonized research
so i just a couple things to point out
here because people will make statements
about one of these being better than the
other and just kind of understanding
what makes them different
fundamentally pcornet has a traditional
relational database that it uses
and the tables represent familiar
clinical domains pretty intuitive with
diagnoses and labs and mets each living
in their own table
where i2b2 uses a star schema model and
so it has one large fact table that has
all of those individual observations
stacked together regardless of domain
and then it has different ontology
tables that describe the hierarchical
relationships between the rows and the
fact table
and then omop is a hybrid of those two
so
it kind of takes the best of both
and we have the domain tables like we do
in pcornet and then an individual
concept table that becomes kind of like
a data dictionary containing all of the
terms and then other concept
relationship tables as well
so here are some of the tools that make
use of this data
uh well epic it's actually just taking
the raw underlying data out of your uh
your epic slicer dicer rather taking
your local emr data
and
displaying that
through through a query mechanism not
all epic data is provided in epic slicer
dicer it's has to be implemented at the
site level
and it is pretty limited in its
interface
and then we have you know beef and
trinidax as other examples of tools and
these are running off of
structured data i2 b2 data or itv2
oromop in the case of trinetics or
pcornet so
does this make your data more findable
and accessible
at least an aggregate yes does
but do the queries really expose the
full complexity of the underlying data
i would say no we've already talked
about how the emrs are different across
sites
and so slicer dicer is really not
interoperable
and then
you know leaf and trinidex require that
mapping so we have some harmonization to
a cdm but they're not implemented in the
same way by all sites so for example
trinetx does not dictate whether
ordered inpatient meds that are not
actually administered
to the patient appear in the data set
and it doesn't provide a flag so you
might have some sites where a whole
bunch of things that were ordered and
not given are exposed as patient meds
and you might have another site where
only the given inpatient meds are
exposed
and at uva we have a data dictionary
available to our users that explains
that we are selecting just the given
inpatient meds and then any ordered
outpatient meds
but you know that's
that kind of
dictionary distinctions not available
across sites who are using trinetx
so we really need to define the
structure of our underlying data and
harmonize our data to make our queries
more interoperable across sites
there's a lot of ways that large medical
data sets are shared and i'm just giving
you a few examples here to
illustrate a range of approaches with
regards to interoperability and
and reuse
and on the high entropy end of the scale
we have those globally scoped data
repositories they accept a wide range of
data types in a variety of formats
and they don't really impose a coherent
model
and then the federated model which is
used in act as an example
you can
query across sites but really there's no
sharing of the underlying row level data
and so we can't under we can't really
understand the differences of how that
result came about we just get the
aggregate answer coming back from the
site
and then we have centralized data where
all the row level data is combined prior
to cleaning and analysis
and so n3c is the example today and
i will spend some more time talking
about that project and the omop data
that it uses
um i've also included in the reference
slides a reference to paper i worked on
with emily faff and a bunch of others
who
are working in n3c and it illustrates
how centralizing our data in one place
has really helped us better understand
our differences and
bridge those gaps and even enhance our
local data mappings and
increasing operability and even
increasing the quality of the federated
queries that we're doing
outside of n3c
so now i'll go a little deeper into
the omap common
data model
as i had said before it does build off
of the strengths of the previously
developed
data models and it's a partnership
between
the fda nih pharma and academia at this
point and it's a mechanism and a nice
quote here a mechanism to standardize
the structure content and semantics of
observational data and to make it
possible to write statistical code
once that can be reused at every data
site
so that's the vision and worldwide we
got lots of volunteers working on
on this data model
the community that's gathered around it
is odyssey
and it's an open science community that
builds and also validates tools that
that sit on top of this data model
a really rich set of open source tools
so
i've given you a link here to this
online book about
about odyssey and omop
and
it's really really helpful and you might
be particularly interested in
chapters four and five for your work
so take a look at that it's really well
organized
and then if you want to learn more about
the stuff we've talked about so far
there's a good tutorial
from the 2019 odyssey symposium that i
would recommend
so this is an illustration of the omop
clinical data model domains
and
again you can see that we have
these kind of domain based tables
intuitive types of facts in them each
representing person level data and the
purchasing table itself contains some
basic demographics about those people we
have location data we have
derived elements where we look across
time of things and see the start and
stop of conditions or drugs
and
if we of course have some standardized
metadata about the source facts then
here's all these relational tables the
concept table which is like a data
dictionary
and then a lot of things describing the
relationships between them
so here's a little peek into one entry
in the concept table
all of the source concepts are indexed
in the concept table
along with a mapping to a hierarchical
omop code
so odyssey maintains the standard set of
codes typically snomed lincoln rx norm
so three or just a few
vocabularies are used rather than
75 plus
and they also maintain the hierarchical
relationships between those codes
and so we have complete mappings from
all non-standard codes to a set of
standard codes with a much more discrete
set of hierarchies that define them so
this is really um wonderful work that's
being done you know across across the
world that makes this uh
makes this clinical data model so so
powerful
so omap
relies heavily on snomed ct whenever
it's possible it uses it for the
standard vocabulary
and this slide is an excerpt from the
national library of medicine websites
you can go there that kind of
abbreviated their history here to just
pull out a few of the facts
but it does show how
snomed efforts really originated from
work being done by pathologists to
standardize
the anatomical descriptions
and then the development continued to be
driven by clinicians
not like billing practices like some of
our other coding systems
so i will note that icd-11 which is
coming out is much more tightly aligned
to snomed so it's starting to converge
towards the standard itself
at the 2020 symposium odyssey symposium
benjamin b rnase and his team presented
the poster that shows the power of using
the snomed ct hierarchy compared to the
icd hierarchy in terms of the
completeness and the richness of data
captured and he was looking particularly
at computation of the charleston
comorbidity index
using the two systems and snomed was the
clear winner based on their work they
used some veteran affairs data
and they saw higher average cmi scores
when they applied snowmen
so i kind of replicated this exercise in
n3c and found that their fightings hold
through in this much much larger data
set as well
on this slide i show counts
for total concept sets in just a
congestive heart failure concept set
created with the two methods
so if you use snomed
you can identify one parent code
and use all of its descendants and map
codes you get 428 source codes included
compared to using
icd codes where you have the 24 icd
codes that were originally
recognized as part of
the this comorbidity and the charleston
comorbidity index and if you take all of
its descendants and all of its map codes
you get 231
and you know a review of those concepts
shows that relevance holds up in these
and there are maybe a couple in here
that that might not um apply
so i provided a few links for you all
here so you can explore these
hierarchies there's
these are publicly available tools that
sit on top of the omop data model and
give you kind of a way to look into the
guts of it
so athena is a great one to look at for
exploring the vocabs and the hierarchies
and then atlas is one of those tools
another tool that's created by the
odyssey community it's open source you
might have an atlas instance stood up at
your particular institution that's
sitting on top of your omop data
but there are a few public instances
also for um
that anyone can log on and use and this
is one
where they they use some large
international data sets as the
underlying data so you can get a sense
of kind of the frequency of use of
different codes because it's actually
tied to real data
and then also be looking at those
hierarchical relationships that we saw
in athena so here's an example you can
go on you can even search this example
if you go in here you can you can mess
with it too you can mess with my example
because everyone can can change each
other's things in this system
but so this is a ischemic code ischemic
stroke code set
and i've selected just eight standard
codes and they're descendants and then
any non-standard codes that are mapped
to them and that results in a total of
835 included source concepts
so by grabbing just a few
and trusting the work of the community
you can grab all of them very quickly or
you can go and review all of the
included concepts one by one and ensure
they really do
you know fit your purposes and exclude
any that do not
so let's talk a little more about n3c as
an example of centralized omap data
this partnership was facilitated by
ncats
and also cd2h which is a
kind of cross-ctsa group working on
informatics
they provide centralized secure portal
for storage and analysis of
patient-level clinical data to answer
questions related to covid19 so there's
two
websites provided here
and i encourage you to go and take a
look and get involved if you are not
already it's a great learning
environment and
a lot of open meetings and domain teams
that you can join and
a really easy place to plug in to trying
to learn to work with this complex data
whose data is an n3c so the intention of
this again is to answer questions about
covid so all of the participating local
sites run a query to find patients
who've had a positive covet test this
actually includes uh pcr ag or even
antibody so at this point that's that
could just indicate vaccine as well
or a cova diagnosis
and it includes some suspected cases um
from january to may of 2020 when we
didn't have the testing and the and the
diagnosis codes available to us so
there's a we have to have more than one
number of diagnoses to be included in
this group
so it selects all those patients and
some of their records that we'll show
and then it also selects two control
patients
for every every included patients and
these may or may not have had coven but
they at least had
some cove at least one cova test present
with a negative result to be included
and then which data is transmitted it's
all of the major medical facts
from from the participating sites
as long as it's from been recorded since
the beginning of 2018 to now so we don't
have their whole lifetime of chart data
and of course emrs kind of vary in in
their
length of time that they represent
but everyone has data from 2018 forward
and all of those facts are sent and all
of the data from those main all map
tables comes through
and you don't have to have omap to
participate and you actually can
have i2b2 or e or pcornet if you
participate in any of act trend index or
pcornet you can have your data
transferred in from your site
um or omop you can send directly your
omop data in
the data transfer agreement's executed
there's a central irb from hopkins that
we rely on and
um the etl is is
performed periodically typically once a
week for us it's once a week at our
institution um to send this data and
that's ingested
harmonized so if you didn't come from an
omop data model they take your model and
map it onto omop
and then you have it available based on
the approval you get you have to request
use under a data use request
which may or may not require an irb
depending on the level of data you're
trying to access in your own local
practices
but the platform helps you manage all
that
in addition to the limited data set
there's actually de-identify data which
is not shown here with
date shifted that's date shifted data
and then also synthetic data which is
derived
and you know synthetically recreated
from the from the existing data and
provides an even higher level of
de-identification
so here's a snapshot from november 11th
and at that time we had 67 sites 9.2
million patients
over 3 million copied positive patients
over 10 billion rows of data
so really a lot of information it's a
little overwhelming the first time
you face it
and i thrive in n3c we've had a really
good time working with with this
community
um it's been such an honor and a great
thing for our institution to be involved
and it continues to be that
um so we are involved in the neurodomain
team myself and
the pis from i thrive and a number of
clinicians
from uva then also from other sites like
emory and
university of miami
we all lead a neurodomain team and if
you look on the main website there's
this is our domain team but there's all
kinds of domain teams you can
join
it's it's a really great thing
and then we also lead the logic liaison
team and that's just a group of people
who
we found all of the coders working for
the different domain teams and come
together kind of formed a work group
where we can focus our efforts and
create some generic tools for the
community at large
within a domain team
a logic liaison will help
you know go from those those billions of
rows of data to some discrete variables
that can be used in a project
so for example
we saw the ischemic stroke concept set
so we went from hundreds of codes
to eight codes two to one you can name
it put it together into one concept set
and then out of that you can use that in
a complex variable like uh
you know if you wanted to do a covet and
stroke variable where you're looking for
the first instance of one of those codes
and it has to be admitted with an
admission and it has to have had a
coveted positive test in a specific time
period leading up to the stroke
all of that logic can can produce a
single derived variable that can be used
to define a cohort or to be used as an
independent or dependent variable in an
analysis
and when we do that kind of work we
actually have ways that we can share it
back with the community as well
so that people are not all recreating
the wheel
so in working in n3c we run into the
same kinds of challenges and limitations
that we see with
with all coded health data
um you know you really can't lose sight
of those nuances when you're creating
those kind of derived variables or using
them if somebody has produced it for you
for using a statistical or
machine learning model
we have to think about
how did the code appear in the chart
again what was that underlying clinical
workflow and when might something be
captured or not captured
is this patient report is this an
official diagnosis was it an ordered
medication or given medication do we
know
do we have to know for the particular
question that we're asking is that
really important to know the distinction
there
you know the start date the first time
that you see a code might not be the
time it actually started someone could
have
experienced the condition previously in
their medical history but walked in the
door for the first time at your site and
had it recorded for the first time there
so you might need to look again at
coinciding with a number of other codes
that it would indicate a real event for
the first time like an admission with a
stroker certain kinds of imaging
happening at the same time or drugs
also remember that medical record data
is always inherently incomplete
so you think about all the people
flowing through to n3c where they were
just seen for a cova test and they never
went back to that medical center
so just because they don't have a
complete medical history doesn't mean
that they have no comorbidities so if
you just look you know for the presence
of comorbidities and assume everybody
else was a negative for that you're
misinterpreting the data but you can
look for some
you know richness in the data and only
include patients who have a certain
number of say visits or facts before an
event happened or after event happened
and limit your analysis to those working
with inpatients is a good way to make
sure you're focused on patients who did
have some more comprehensive data
collected at the medical center
but it really depends on your research
question what's appropriate for you
with all medical record data we have
racial biases and data collection
practices even before it ever comes to
us
there could be
differences in care provided to patients
or access to care
there could be issues with the
collection of the race and ethnicity
data we know that it's not always
self-reported information unfortunately
sometimes it's assumed and recorded by a
registrationist
and their systems might not always allow
for things like multiple race values so
you know
just because something looks simple you
know we have to still remember that that
it underneath that there's a lot of
complexity
and then of course medical records from
a specific institution
never represent a true random sample of
the population at that locality
so you know we can't
look at say the rates of of uh
comorbidities and encoded patients in
n3c and say that's a rate for the entire
country
it's just for those patients and the
people who seek care at a medical center
of course are going to
tend to be sicker than the population at
large you're not getting as many of the
healthy patients or people with fewer
issues going on
and then also like we've talked about
before there's variation in clinical
practice across
sites and even departments and
clinicians and it also changes over time
all of our all of our practices change
over time the coding practices as well
as the things that surround it and
covet is a great example where we know
that you know vaccines change things a
great deal so
i think we're all becoming familiar with
these concepts
and then some diagnosis information
might live only in notes and text mining
is complex it's not always an option
we're working to incorporate more of
that into n3c with some text mining done
externally in your notes data
with some
kind of aggregated information or
derived information flowing through
that's in process
so be intentional with how you handle
your data heterogeneity including
over time
right and a lot of observational health
data has those different kinds of
missingness i talked about a little bit
already
so if you create a flag for
bmi over 30 a patient might have a zero
flag for this feature because
all of their reported bmis were under
30. but they also might get a zero value
for this feature if there are no bmi
measurements flowing over from their
site at all
and ideally these zero values are
handled you know differently during data
cleaning or filtering or imputation so
look for those patterns of of
missingness in your data
in general you're going to have a bigger
data set it's it's messier and it might
become more opaque to you what are those
underlying practices because you're not
directly connected with all of the
clinical teams producing that data
so be explicit about your assumptions
and and test them when you're working
with this kind of data
and for the analysts we have to think
about which type of model should be used
there's definitely a place for both
explanatory and predictive modeling
we do usually see
more of the explanatory models with
clinical data because they're easier to
interpret and
apply
and then the predictive modeling
is really less about the why and more
about accurate forecasting of what's
going to happen
but i liked this quote from schmule here
that the consequence of neglecting to
include predictive modeling and testing
alongside explanatory modeling
is losing the ability to test the
relevance of ex of existing theories and
discover new causal
mechanisms
so you know it's really the one informs
the other and you may
need to kind of use the two side by side
so just a few summary data science
considerations
apply to
most work that you're ever going to do
even outside of this domain but
make sure the problems represented
in the available data
that you're actually getting all the
facts you need if you're doing something
about ventilation of these patients
do you really do you really have all the
ventilator settings and things that
might be pertinent to your question that
type of thing
um after harmonizing the data you do
have to think about that that
aggregation and make sure you record all
your decisions you're making as you
aggregate that data so that it's
reproducible by other people including
like the concept set creation and the
logic around it
with training and testing you might
consider with medical record data doing
the split
using time intervals so you can look for
tests to your models to see how well do
they handle data as it changes over time
at a clinical site
and then external validation is always
important with the
this centralized data in n3c we have an
opportunity to do external validation by
first training on a number of sites data
training and testing there and then kind
of deploying it out to data from other
partners who are contributing data and
seeing how it performs there
and of course there's no free lunch and
you know at some point maybe
the problem that you're looking at at
one institution or one set of
institutions is essentially really not
the same problem at another institution
so
even giving them the same model to train
on their own data might not be
appropriate in every case
i wanted to point out these um
nice odyssey r libraries that are
available for your use there's again so
much material out there from odyssey but
it's good to highlight some some of the
really useful stuff so the feature
extraction library pro lets you leverage
those snomed codes to create those
commonly used clinical variables
take a look at that it's got good
documentation around it
and then there's a whole set of packages
for
patient level prediction
and
uh that helps you again extract your
data to create variables from a mop and
then
develop and validate models for all
target and outcome cohort validation or
combinations
and
it makes use of all kinds of different
models and regression and machine
learning models and it also supports
custom models that you create
and there are packages included for
plotting and and model performance and
things like that on a shiny app so you
can visualize your results
so i i wanted to talk a little bit share
a little bit of the vision from the
ncats and nih
about use of this data you know n3c has
provided nih and the federal government
with a successful example of what it's
like to centralize data in a secure
enclave
and they're now making plans to enhance
and generalize this model for use beyond
coven 19.
all of this federated work and kind of
project by project
trying to
find the data and transfer between
institutions and store it has
constituted so much work for people
doing research around the country and
they're really realizing that the value
add and
cost savings by centralizing our data
so for one they they plan to provide
translation software
um the bulk emr
extract the bulk fire extract from our
emr aligns with the tefka
requirements that are coming out the
previously mentioned 21st century cures
act that supports that exchange of data
between emrs
bulk fire is really like a language i
can speak to your emr and pull those
facts out
and
nih will provide it all of us
participants with those tools you know
to to actually go both ways from fire to
one of the data models or
use data that you have in one of the
data models to communicate with other
entities that need to use that data like
the cdc or the fda
or you know any of your nih research
teams
and i also want to enhance the secure
enclave by supporting project-based
spin-off environments
they call it the tenant model
and these would support two or more
institutions that are trying to do
networked
medical record research
and the appropriate data you know it
would already all be housed since they
would have all the underlying data
but they can make a subset of that
available
projects for specific partition
in the enclave along with all of those
rich analytic tools that are being
developed by the research community at
large
this is really exciting and and will
help us all not have to recreate the
wheel so many times and
build you know
a
whole set of tools that we can share and
use together
so i have some key takeaways for you
most of all we'd like that i like to
know your medical coding vocabularies
understand which one you're using or or
several that you're using
and then leverage those community tools
like the odyssey resources that i
described to create groups of codes for
your derived variables in your data set
and use data that is mapped to common
data models whenever possible
apply standard data science good
practices
test your assumptions
strive for completeness consistency and
uniformity
and work with your domain experts to
understand data collection
and work on variable definition and
problem design
it's really a team science problem
don't recreate the wheel and use those
community developed libraries
so in conclusion i just want to say it's
not our software systems alone that
require common language it's our
research teams also we have to become
fluent in a common language so that
our clinicians our informations and
analysts can effectively partner
together and do rigorous and
reproducible science using this real
world data
and i believe that the future of
clinical translational research really
revolves around bioinformatics
and by work by working to use and
improve the evolving systems around us
we can all help move this field forward
and i think that's all i have i have
some references at the end for you all
to take a look at
johanna thank you so much that was a
wonderful overview of the various
sources of uh structured medical records
data um thank you so much for sharing
that with us um i was impressed where
you on one of your slides you mentioned
6.5 million unique codes uh that is a
staggering number of codes i'm kind of
curious they
how that gets to be 6.5 million unique
codes i presume that you know somebody
makes these up what happens to the to
codes that exist and like when can they
be revised or remapped do they get
retired or does the list just grow right
it never gets smaller it only grows
longer as people just add more and more
codes but what happens in those
instances
yeah they they do get retired and
remapped so you know there are different
groups that manage the different
vocabularies but you're familiar with
icd codes coming out with different
versions and so
you know the entire
version changes and even the hierarchies
they use and the codes they use can
change entirely
and in a way the old one is sunset at
sunsetted but you can't forget about it
because all this premium that's right
was used with those codes right and so
you have to maintain those mappings from
the old ones right to the new and or
from all of them to standard codes
the omop
data model is being updated all the time
and then you know we get we get the kind
of updates ingested into n3c on a
regular basis so it's a big community
effort and there are formats where you
can give feedback to um
to have that to have the revised if you
you know recognize that there are
problems with it
but yeah it is
it is an issue it's there's always
version control with everything that you
do in informatics so you have to be
mindful of that yeah i'm working with
some students now who are working with
the unos
organ transplant database and it's a
huge
database it covers every medical center
in the country and it's been around long
enough that it's gone through several
revisions and there's a whole several
places where there
in our discussions with them say oh yeah
we don't really use that term anymore
it's really we use this term or rather
they do a number of other things so
you're really
overriding all of this is dealing with
the evolution of the particular database
in question would you agree with that
yeah i agree and i i think that yeah you
you have to do two things you kind of
start with relying on work done by the
community especially if you're using
able to use omop
um but then you can backtrack from there
and and say do i really trust this and
like i was saying kind of dive into a
particular list of codes to see or work
with the teams that generated the data
for any particular database to find out
the true provenance of that
i i try to go you know through each each
type of code we're using and say
how is this code generated what are all
the circumstances where this code would
be generated
and you know often what you see is that
the clinicians who are
you know conceptualizing the problem
think of a code as used by them
and don't necessarily think of all the
broad range of cases where it can be
used
so if you have tools like
trinetics at your disposal or leaf
you know you can take a look at those
codes and see
other pla other instances where it's
used in other you kind of surface these
cohorts that maybe a clinician would not
have thought about these patient cohorts
where where that kind of code is is used
so
do some exploring you know we every
single project we work on it seems easy
at first
and
pass
every pass we know it surfaces more
questions and of course you have to pick
and choose at some point and decide
where are we really adding value
so it's also important you know you
might have
the 6.5 billion um
codes used but if one only appears three
times or something and you don't want to
spend too much time worrying about that
particular code right so um yeah you
it's important to
look at use you know the rate of use for
the underlying facts as well yeah so
with 6.5 million unique codes there's
probably a frequency which some of them
get used more than others it is probably
helpful to know about that uh as you're
as you're looking through i i
completely agree with your statement
that bioinformatics and being able to
process these uh being experienced with
this is really helpful um and it one
should take the time to be able to um
you know educate oneself about which
resource they happen to be using i'm
curious though if you know where you
have these codes which
usually they've been standardized or
certainly they've been decided upon by
either the developers or the community
around them i'm curious though are there
also um
blocks of free text that are associated
with any of these that say maybe
suitable for natural language processing
or
trying to use information in clinical
notes for example to then inform which
codes one might want to attach to data
or draw from data does that make sense
yeah absolutely like notes data imaging
data all kinds of data that's um not not
so discrete encoded data
can be really valuable for any research
study so you know we were focused on the
coded data today but you could
absolutely
design and people design nlp algorithms
to run on say notes data and then try to
map
those to
the existing
codes so there might be things that
could have been coded but weren't coded
or you might just be going for a totally
different concept something that might
not ever appear
in a code typically and create a
different kind of a variable out of
those things
you know with harmonization and
centralization you get extra hurdles
with working with that kind of
data but we are
we are tackling those again at the
national scale and and kind of solving
those problems it's just really
wonderful to see um what it you know how
everybody came with such open
open-handed
uh good intentions um in the early
pandemic and i think we all thought we
were diving in for a couple
little months we know
right
right but um
but it's so exciting and it's such an
honor for me to work alongside these
these experts you know whose
publications i've read and admired and
and they're just right there accessible
to all of us you know you just join any
of these public meetings and you can
jump in and and work right alongside
them
so um
it's a wonderful community
format and one that melissa hendell one
of the pis i think calls social anarchy
you know it's it really is um a
different model and one word that we're
trying to get attribution
to apply to people doing some of the
work that gets hidden and maybe people
get credit that that wouldn't always get
credit for doing this work so folks who
are creating these large you know tools
that can be used across the community
giving them some recognition as well as
these publications come out
one of the things that you mentioned in
one of your comments one of your slides
you talked about the fair principles and
certainly it's something for us who are
doing you know empirical work um in
patient samples versus controls or we're
developing tools you know data and
software are things that we want to see
be findable accessible interoperable and
reusable
in what ways are the communities around
this like taking that seriously um how
are they opening these up making the
data and the results more reusable by
people who are not part of those
communities does that make sense
yeah so um
you know trying to align with open
source things as much as possible is
very important for for reproducibility
um we are encouraging everyone who's
publishing out of n3c for example to
also publish the concept sets that they
used for their
creation of their variables because
different decisions go go into that with
every group and you can try to describe
those decisions but having the actual
you know list of codes used to define
something like heart failure
is also critical for trying to reproduce
it at your own institution and will save
a ton of time for those who are trying
to reproduce the work
you know github is used for a lot of the
odyssey
code and you know it's widely available
there um inside the enclave there's kind
of a custom interface
where we write chunks of code and and
create pipelines inside of there not all
of that is easily exportable to the
outside at least in a reusable way you
can actu you can pull it out but it's
not fairly reusable so
we're working on i'm making that a
little bit better but of course anyone
can join into that in that enclave with
the data use agreement
and then access any of the code that's
been templatized and um that's that's
really i mean sometimes there's so much
available out there that the challenge
is not
can we share it but how do you find
what's meaningful yeah what and so we're
also working on the documentation
process around that so for the concept
sets that we're sharing um we're
asking that people and it's all
voluntary but people document the
provenance of that you know the aims of
creating that particular one um and the
known limitations around that concept
says he would say we're trying to be
really conservative with this one
because we don't want any false
positives for these reasons etc right
and that helps for someone who browses
and finds there's 20 different asthma
concept sets they can review the notes
and say well i'm going to start off with
this one because that sounds closest to
what i'm aiming to do
and similarly we're working to create a
computable protocol
structure where
a lot of these things like the pointing
to underlying concept sets the
descriptions of the logic
that creates the derived variables
becomes
you know extracted and exposed anywhere
where it needs to be exposed in any kind
of lab notebook type of a thing or
any database as you're ingesting it you
can see that that data where it came
from
um and
that can be tied to your protocol and
you can kind of point to these bits and
pieces and chunks
so that will really help enhance
reusability
my team the logic liaisons we really
work to to make
to make curated
templates with curated underlying
variables
that are broadly used so as we watch the
community work and we see a lot of
people doing something similar but
different
we write code and we select concept sets
and we create good documentation around
that
so that people can go to something
pretty generic
that runs well though that they can take
and copy and paste and modify code for
their own purposes or just use the
output of one of these pipelines
so yeah the reusability is is always a
a combination of the tools to create the
metadata and expose the metadata and
share that share all those artifacts and
the curation
aspect
and the metadata needs to reflect that
curation somehow
one thing that is one of our themes this
year is in addition to being able to do
computing against a resource like this
or perhaps apply artificial intelligence
methods and such is
understanding the sources of bias
that may affect the ethical use of
certain data um how you know certain
factors about our culture or society may
get baked into certain resources and
anyway i'm just kind of curious if in
some of these resources where might the
challenges be and like for example in
some of these which are say associated
with the
medical records um associated with major
medical centers might there be sort of a
bias towards you know large urban areas
in contrast to maybe more rural areas
are those things to be worried about as
one is looking at these resources
yeah i mean i think it again depends on
the question that you're asking and some
you need to be more sensitive to that
type of context than others
we were just today actually working on
making it easier to
access the social determinants of health
data like the sdi index or a variety of
other projects like
sharepoint and other ones
make it a little easier to have those
facts tied to the patients and
you know it's possible now but when you
have to go and do a lot of custom coding
to get there
you know it might dissuade people from
making use of that and so
we're trying to make that easier so
people can stratify or use that when
they're doing matching
it's very very important that that the
data be looked at site by site no matter
what you're doing again for completeness
of variables
or you know use it
you might use it at the site in a mixed
effects model to look at the effects of
that site
yeah very very important
and do people when they use these do
they need to be um do they have to have
like city training or some any special
training to be able to um have access to
these uh resources
yeah so again i've been focused on n3c
and you do have to have human subjects
training and you do complete the
and that can be your local human
subjects training it has to just be
current um and then you have to do an
nih security training which
is is generic training for people who
work there so it's like when you travel
with your government laptop are you
being safe with it things like that
um but uh you know we we do that um and
reviews certain policies and standards
you know the the data that comes out has
to be aggregated at a minimum cell size
of 20. a lot of other database
databases people might work with it
maybe 10 as the threshold that's a cms
minimum but that just means you can
never make a statement that
exposes a group smaller than 10 you know
even when you look at all the different
ways your data converges
um and percentages of bigger numbers and
things like that you don't you don't
want to ever expose a very small group
of people because that leads to risk of
re-identification
sure
one final question uh one of our
listeners is asking um
along with the um n3c data and all the
codes that it has and it's what did you
say am i is this number right 50 million
records is that correct
um there's over three million code
positive patients and about 10 million
i think total or so i can't remember oh
my gosh well it's still a staggering
10 10 billion rows of data yeah but
among among those in addition to the
codes is there also um
free text associated with those records
as well
the notes data we are we are working on
making that available from all sites
there are a few sites that are doing
some early work with that
and then but what would be available
would not be the raw notes data because
that is just it's too risky but rather
the nlp pipelines would be run on your
local data to then extract some you know
synthesized facts about the notes data
well johanna
thank you so very much for summarizing
all of these important resources for us
this is really uh an exciting uh
collection of resources we're
particularly interested to learn about
your work with the um the covid
consortium and the promise that that has
for helping us to kind of get our hands
around this and all the codes that gosh
this staggering amount of codes that
we're gonna have to get used to oh my
goodness um but thank you so much for
for sharing this with us we really
appreciate it and um uh thank you
everyone who is listening with us uh
we're going to be taking next week off
in honor of the thanksgiving holiday
here in the united states but uh with
that everybody have a wonderful weekend
and we'll see you uh two weeks from now
um at our next biomedical data science
seminar series have a great week